サーリプッタ尊者かそれが解釈しちゃうんですね
そういうことはまた経典の中に入ってるんですね
いわゆるこのサンユッタ・ニカーヤとかね
そういうアングッカラ・ニカーヤとか
そういう経典の中にそういうエピソードまで入ってるんですから
この経典出来上がる前も
いわゆるサーリプッタ尊者たちやら
そういう偉大な阿羅漢たちがいた時でも
もう経典としてもしっかりできていたんですね
だから経典としてできるのは
やっぱりこの本人が亡くなってからなんですけどね
言ったものをまとめられるのでも
本人 いわゆるお釈迦様が説法している間でも
もうその前にそれはもう固めてあったものなんですね
ですから かなり古い経典として大変ありがたく考えているところなんですね
ですから このスッタっていうのは
あの 意図の意味であって
この でも意図という意味というよりも
このフォーミュラという英語の言葉ありますね
フォーミュラって日本語になると何といいますか
たまに来るんだから  英語の勉強
専門家だから フォーミュラって何て言います？ フォーミュラはまあ
あれですね まあシステムじゃないですけど
まあ何と言いますかね
式ですね 数学で言えば式
一応その式って意味なんですけど
数学の式は まあそれはそれなりに式なんですけど
この哲学文 あの文法の場合も
この式みたいなものを作ってそれから語るというのは
一応ヨーロッパであるかどうかはわかりませんけど
インドではよくあるんですね
式と言ったっても それは一つの文章なんです
その文章の中に言いたいものは全部入ってるんです
でもそれだけでは理解できない
それでいろんな先生たちが
それはどのように理解するべきかと
このずっと長い文章で解釈したりする
いわゆる式があって 式に論文を書くっていうような感じなんですね
今の風に言えば 例えば論文の場合は一行で書ける結論があるんですね
この一行で書ける結論だけ書いちゃっても
誰も認めてくれません
ですから いっぱい情報やら
いろんな対照することやら
比較することやら ぜんぶ書いて
故にこういうことですよと
最終的には結論を出すんですね
ですから 哲学的に語れば
こういうスッタっていうのは一応結論のまとまり
まとめみたいなものなんです
ですから サンスクリット語の文法
これは紀元六世紀で作られたんだけど
パーニニさんの そのパーニニの文法のテキストも全部式だけなんですね
式と言ったっても 一応文章
文章 文章 文章だけであって
それはいろんなこのサンスクリット語自体の中のいろんなこの言葉の使い方について
このように使いますよと一行書いておくんですね
ですから その行に番号つけてあって
だからパーニニの百三番と言えば
まあ大体覚えて それを暗記するんです
その式全部 一旦式を暗記して解釈聞いてみたら
もう文法はバッチリと
もう全く間違わないんですね
何も疑いなく 迷うことなく
もう書いたり理解したりすることはできるんです
で パーニニだけではなくて
他のパーリ語にもそうやって文法の式のテキストがあるんです
で そういうのは大体暗記するんです
暗記しちゃったら もう文法はもう絶対間違わないんです
もう式は暗記しているんだから
そこで哲学の場合でも
もうその先生が言ったことは全く間違わないように
その通りに理解したいと思えば
その式の形に言ってる文章
そのものを覚えておけばいいんです
それでお釈迦様の教えっていうのは全てスッタと言うんですね
スッタと言うんですね
ですから そのまま暗記するしか方法ない
暗記しておけば もうお釈迦様おっしゃったことは間違わない
で理解できるんですね
暗記しておかないで 意味だけ覚えておくと
確実に間違ってしまっちゃうんですね
意味だけ覚えておくと
だからテーラワーダでは
その意味だけ理解して説法することは
まあやめなさいと 説法師にはなれませんと
いい加減になるんだと
だから意味だけ覚えておけば
これはさらに自分が意味を説明しちゃうと
お釈迦様の意見ではなくて自分の意見になってしまっちゃうんですね
だから次の時代に伝えてほしいのは
自分の意見ではなくて
完全たるお釈迦様の意見なんですね
だから仏教徒として私がそう思います
私はこう思いますよと
仏教はこうであるべきですよということ自体は邪見であって
絶対やってはいけないことで
ですから 説法する時はいつでも気をつけて気をつけて
もう解釈はするんだけど
いつでもお釈迦様の言葉が先に出して
それに解釈する ただ 解釈なしに聞く側が理解には理解できません
聞く側が理解するのは解釈なんです
でも その解釈はいつでも識があって
その識の分析ですから
お釈迦様の意見からは逸れることはないんですね
だから解釈は現代の聞いている人々の理解の範囲の中で
その社会の中で理解できるようにするものですからね
でも 理解した部分がほぼ間違ってないということになっちゃうんですね
そういうことで この説法する時は
いつでもこのお釈迦様の言葉一つあって
その言葉の解釈として説法するということがあるんですよ
で その中でもテキスト自体にスッタという名前をつけているのはこれだけなんですね
例えば長部経典ありますね
それは長部経典とディーゲニカータと言うんです
それで長部経典の経典一つの最後に名前にスッタンとつけちゃうんです
なになに経と でも 経典のボディの体のボディの中にスッタというものが入ったことはないんです
だから このテキストの名前自体もスッタニパータと
だからニパータっていうのはどういう意味かというと
そこはちょっと分かりにくいんだけど
このブッダガヤ長老もいろいろ定義はしていますけどね
なかなか分かりにくくて
大体ニパータっていうのは
このまあ集まりという意味でよろしいんですね
ですからスッタの集みたいな
編集みたいなものでね
だからスッタの ブッダの教えの識の編集でしたから
もう大変昔から大事に覚えておいて
でもこれ注釈書読むと
これ今世紀では終われないと思います
[笑い] そういうわけで
このスッタニパータテキストにも
あの 偈一つ一つに番号を振ってるんです
終わりまで ですから スッタニパータに引用する場合は
スッタニパータの十五と言えば十五番目の偈で
十八とかね 二十三とか三十とか百一とか言ったら
この経典の名前ではなくて
全部偈に番号を振ってるんです
それはまあ 学者の中で
共通的に  認めている数字なんですね
それまあ 昔 遠い昔からも
パーリ聖典 このローマ字になる以前も
印刷する以前も そういう番号
まあ一応ついてあったんです
スッタ あの大体スートラの場合は
この  十個 十個 一つのカテゴリーに入れてますからね
で この場合は このウラガ
ワッグ ウラガっていうのはヘビなんですけど
ヘビの章で一番目の経典は
ウラガ・スッタ ヘビの経
経です ヘビのスッタですね
中村先生はヘビだけで訳してるんです
で このヘビの経典は もうそれほど
難しくないでしょうと思いますから
じゃあ一番目読んでみます
よー うっぱてたん いねえ
ティコ だん いさたん さっぴゃ
びさん うお さでい そう
びっく じゃはー ティオー
ら ぱーらん うらご じんな
みわ たちゃん ぷらーなん
よー うっぱてたん いねえ
ティコ だん いさたん さっぴゃ
びさん うお さでい そう
びっく じゃはー ティオー
ら ぱーらん うらご じんな
みわ たちゃん ぷらーなん
この偈の この書き方なんですけど
これ一番古い書き方で
現代の称名では  少々言いにくいやり方なんです
で あの 慈悲経も同じで
このすごい古い経典では
なんかこの 二行目は長くて
一行目は短いという  決まりは決まりなんですけど
で 称名の場合は  結構苦しいんです
合わせるのは で 意味は
日本訳はまとめに訳していると思います
ヘビの毒がいろいろあるのを恐れて静するように
怒りが起こったのを静する
修行者はこの世とこの世とを共に捨て去る
この経典にヘビということはね
分かりやすいんですから
ずっとこのヘビの脱皮のことを書いてるんですからね
で だからヘビ 同音異義語のヘビと言えば
すぐ  毒ということも入ってくるし
それからヘビの特色というのは
脱皮するんですね うーん
デパートなんかには行かないんですね
服なんか買うとか 古くなったら捨てればいいんです
[笑い]だからヘビはいつでも
あの 体は綺麗です 他の動物と比べると
あれほど体が綺麗な動物はいないと思いますけど
他の動物っていうのは
臭くて 体が汚くて ノミやら
ね いっぱいいて大変なんです
ヘビの体には別に虫でも何もいない
あれ ビニール製品みたいなもんだから
で あれ  古くなってくると色が変わってきますね
それで これ もう 全部捨てちゃうんですね
あの 細い枝なんかの間で
こうやっていけば もう
皮が全部 古い皮が残って
ヘビが出ていっちゃうんですね
[背景の音楽]そこで一番目は一番簡単で
この経典だけ不思議で
一番目の経典は簡単で
一偈はもっと簡単で 他の経典の編集の場合はなんか思考逆なんです
一番目の経典はものすごく難しいです
それからどんどんどんどん簡単になっちゃうんですね
やっぱりこれはそうじゃなくて
一番目の偈は簡単になっているんですね
よ ウッパティタン ヴィネティコ
コーダン ヴィネティ よ
誰かが ウッパティタンというのは生まれてきた
現れてきた コーダン 怒りを
ヴィネティ まあコントロールする
なくすという意味なんですね
それから どのようにというと
ヴィサタン サッパヴィサンワ
オーサデーヒ オーサデーヒっていうのは最後の言葉は薬でやって
サッパヴィサンっていうのは毒
蛇の毒 サッパっていうのは蛇という意味なんです
だからヴィサタンっていうのは
この日本訳と同じ この広がる
広がるということ 広がったっていう意味でね
過去分詞ですね という意味は
怒りが生まれる それを広げていく
すぐ薬を飲んで そこ いわゆる毒が入ったら
毒はすぐ体に広げてしまっちゃうんですね
で そこはすぐ薬を飲んで
毒をなくしてもらうんですね
そのような感じで 怒りが体に入ったら
怒りが体中出て行ってしまいますからね
それをなくしてくださいということ
それをなくす人 ソ 比丘
その人は比丘であって
修行者なんですね だから怒りはそのようにコントロールできる人がここで比丘と言っているんですね
修行者だと だから修行と言ったって
並の修行者ではないんですよ
これも修行成功者というかね
もうちゃんとできてる
できた人 タダたんに入ったばっかりの修行者っていう意味よりも
この場合はね 本当にもう一人前のもう合格している修行者のことを言うんですね
だからそういうのはもう単なる訳では入らないんですね
で それはなぜそう意味にとるかということは
延々と他の経典から引用して引用して引用して
これでものすごい長い長い注釈をつけているんです
そのようにとって理解してほしいと
ソ 比丘 ジャハティ オーレ
パーラン オーレ っていうのは
ここ パーラっていうのは
あそこということ いわゆるこの世
あの世なんですね いわゆる輪廻のことなんですね
この世もあの世も捨てるんだと
で 四目裏側 蛇は この次の言葉
ジンナンっていうのは古くなったという
タチャンっていうのは川のこと
トゥラーナンっていうのはまた古く
古くなったという ジンナンっていうのはボロボロになったっていうことで
トゥラーナンっていうのは古くなったっていうこと
だからボロボロになって古くなったタチャン
川ですね イワっていうのはのように
ただそれだけ あの 脱皮するようにとは書いてないんです
そこで大体わかるんです
蛇がボロボロになって
なって 古くなった川のようにというと
それだけで まあもう脱皮するようにという意味が取れるんです
だから この日本語にすると
もういっぱい言葉入れて
入れておかないと理解できないんです
だからパーリ語で読む人にとっては
そのことで結構難しいところ
引っかかるところいっぱいあるんですね
だからどれぐらい言葉で補った方がいいかって
これは大変な問題で まあこの例えだから
それはもう言うまでのことの簡単ですけどね
例えではなくて 中の場合も補わなくちゃいけないところは出てくるんで
理解するためには まあ一応大体これぐらいの意味なんですけど
怒りが生まれたらそれを広げていくということと
体に毒が入ったら毒が体中広げていっちゃうんです
そしたらすぐ早くも待つ時間がないんですね
すぐ早くもその薬を飲んで
その毒を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
それで自分の命を守られるんですね
そのように怒りが生まれたら瞬時にそれを消しなさいということなんですね
で 問題は じゃあ瞬時に消しなさい
それぐらいは誰でも分かります
怒りが生まれる 誰にでも言ったっても
一応誰か誰かがわかるかもしれません
怒りは良くないと思っている人々もこの世の中で少なくないんです
自分が怒っているということにさえも気がつかないんです
貪瞋痴の中で生きてるんだから
この悩んでいるんだ 苦しんでいるんだ
迷っているんだ もうトラブルが多いんだとかね
大変だとか そこのいろんなことを言うのに
その中にもうほとんどの場合はあるのはすごくもう濃縮した怒りなんですね
例えば自分が明るく生活したいんだけど
家は色々トラブルばっかでどうしようもないんだと普通に言っちゃうんで
その時でもあるのは怒りなんですね
だから人は文句言いたくなる
自分の何て言いますか
悩み事とかね 溜まったりする
誰かに言いたくなる カウンセリングしたくなるって
そこ そういう人いっぱいいるでしょう
全てなんのことはない
怒りなんですね 例えば欲がある場合は
誰もカウンセリングは受けません
欲に溺れているんです
人に相談しようともしないんです
それで欲も同じく大変な毒なんですけど
その毒に汚染されて死んでしまっちゃいますけど
結局怒りの場合はあまりにも苦しいんだから
まあ時々いろいろまあ話したり
問題だと思ったりもする
だから人間っていうのは
人間一般的に自分にはいろいろトラブルがあるんだ
問題があるんだと思っちゃったら
これはもう九十九パーセント怒りなんですね
金銭トラブルやら社会関係のトラブルやら
もう精神的なトラブルやら
いろんなトラブル持ってくるでしょうし
もうまとめて全て怒りなんです
そういうことだから これ大変な
この心理的なレベルから見ると
これ大変なことなんです
社会の人々を見ると まあ問題ないんだと
大変楽しく明るく あの
幸せで生きてるんだという人々の数が少ないんですね
もう大変忙しくて ビクビクして生活する人々の方が多いんです
すごい緊張して すごくストレス溜まって生活する人々の方がものすごい多いんです
ということは それは全て怒り
怒りある人々の数っていうのはすごく多い
だからこの場合はそういうものは何もなく
ただこの死だけ言ってるんです
それでお釈迦様の説法になると
色だけではなくて まあ嫉妬のことやら
恨みのことやら 憎しみのことやら
夫婦喧嘩のことやら そういうのはもう簡単単純に複雑ではなくて
分かりやすく もうそれから説法しているんです
でもこちらでは厳密に色だけ言ってるんです
怒りということで 怒りは毒であると
怒りは猛毒であると それだけ覚えておけばいいんです
だから蛇に据えてインド人にとってはね
ものすごく実感ありますからね
どこを見てももうすぐ蛇を見つけることはできるし
それで蛇もいろいろ種類がいて
インドでは結構いますからね
だからもう 一応すぐ瞬時に死ぬ毒の蛇の毒っていうのは種類なんですね
一つは血液に入って心臓麻痺する
もう一つは神経麻痺するっていう種類に
一応科学的に分けてるんです
蛇の種類はたくさんあるんだけど
神経麻痺麻痺するか 心臓麻痺するかという
だからその種類を見て
今注射とか薬はありますけどね
注射を打たなくてはいけないんですね
だから今の医学の世界でも
やっぱりこれできればこの IVUっていう
何ですか IVU 多分病院に勤めてるでしょうね
じゃなくて あの血管の中に注射することを何て言いますか
静脈注射  専門家ダメだ
で あの今でもそうするようには言ってるんですね
その方がすぐこの解毒剤体に回っちゃうんですね
その間でもかなりダメージを起こしちゃうんです
体の中に毒が入ったら
これですから この蛇の毒っていうのはそれほど簡単なものじゃないんです
蛇は弱い動物だからね
獲物取れないんでしょう
だからもうやっと何か獲物を捕まったらもう逃げられたら困っちゃうしね
だからすぐ噛んじゃうんです
噛んだ瞬間でもう麻痺して死んじゃうんですね
だから逃げられないんです
それから例えばウサギとかね
大きいものでもちゃんと捕まることできるんですね
パッと捕まったらウサギ大きいんだから噛められないんですね
だからちょっとでもどこかで捕まっちゃえば
それだけで十分です ちょっと捕まったらこのもう跳ねさせますからね
それで少々蛇が待てば
ゆっくりと飲み込むことができます
あの蛇が小さいんだけど
ウサギでも飲み込む時は飲み込みますからね
顎が外れますからね 飲み込んじゃうんです
ですから時間かかるんです
飲み込む時はね まあそういうことで
蛇にとっては大変役に立つもので
蛇にしたっても蛇が回ったら死ぬんです
毒が回ったら 蛇でも犬みたいに体噛むでしょ？犬は
この痒い痒いところは
蛇はそうしません もしこちらちょっと痒いんだから歯で噛んでみようかなと思ったら
蛇は死に[笑い] 犬だったら
今飼ってる犬ではそんなそんな現象はあまり見えませんだけどね
犬はあれすっごい気持ちよくやってる趣味なんです
あっちこっち飲みとかね
いくらかいた方が犬にとっては幸せみたいです
だからそこら辺嗅いだり
噛んだり 噛んだり こちら側噛んだり
噛んだり 時々すごい満足そうな声までするんです
で 体を噛むながら 我々はかくような感じで
犬は歯でカチカチカチカチと噛みますからね
そんな考えであんなこと蛇とやり合っちゃったら
それで死んでしまいます
まあ安全のためかわかりませんだけど
毒が入ってる牙はね 後ろに回ってるんですね
前に出てはないんです
こうやって後ろに だからすごいわかりやすいんです
口が開けたら一番前に二つあります
二本 僕らはもう蛇っていうのはもう身近なもんだから
結構知ってます [笑い]で
後ろに曲がってるんです
だからわざと蛇は口を開けてこうやって刺さないと
それだからまあ剃刀と同じくね
別に触ったって切れるということではなくて
ちょっと間違ったら切れてしまっちゃうということでね
髭なんか紙とかちゃんと平気で剃るでしょうに
でも角度ちょっと間違ったらもうやられちゃいますね
まあそんなもんで この角度がちゃんとあって
普通こうやって触ったっても何も何事でもないんだけどね
あの毒 蛇は毒はそんなすごい死ぬぐらいのものなんですけど
お腹に入ったら何のこともないんです
だから中国人は飲むでしょ
で 飲むのはいいんだけど
もし痒いとかあったら飲まない方がいいんです
で あの胃酸ですぐ溶けちゃいます
毒はタンパク質なんです
もうすごい あのすごい簡単に分解するタンパク質ですから
飲んじゃったらもうすぐもうその場でもう胃の中での分解してしまっちゃいますけどね
それでも万が一ということもありますから
もし胃に行く前に そこら
そこら辺の方で そこら辺
何と言いますか 食道 そこら辺ででもちょっとあの傷跡があったら
まあ成仏できませんということですね
悪いことではないです
だから まあそういうふうなこの知識があった上で
この偈には意味があるんです
蛇の毒っていうのはそういう遊ぶものではないんです
体に入ったらもう死んだものと決めた方がいいんです
日本のあのハブでしたっけ
日本のヘビはハブ あれに噛まれたっても死ぬほどではないんだけど
永久的に残っちゃうでしょ
何かそこら辺のやられたところは
すぐ解毒剤使わないと
で このインドのヘビコブラみたいにね
もうさようならっていうことはないんだけどね
やっぱり死んじゃいますけど
一応治療するほんのちょっとのわずかな時間はあります
あるんだけど そこら辺のその後じゃないんですね
まあ死んじゃうんです
この神経とか ですからもう残るんです
大変なものなんです まあだからお釈迦様はこの怒りというものについて
このように教えて 生まれたら生まれた瞬間に消せと
じゃあどのように消せる
消せ 消せちゃえばいいかとかね
その方法とか そういうのはこちらにこの偈にはないんです
だからこれを面白おかしく読んで
面白いこと言ってるんだとかね
そんな風なこの読む楽しみに日本語訳してますけど
これ読む楽しみのものじゃないんです
これはもうお釈迦様の大変大事な教えで
だから怒りは蛇の毒のようってということで
早く消せっていうぐらいの意味なんですけど
じゃあ早く消せ分かりました
それから勉強なんです
どうやって怒りをすぐ生まれた瞬間で消せるかと
早く消せって言っちゃったって
ただ早く消せるんだったら問題何もないんですからね
そうは消せないんでしょ
怒りが生まれた瞬間に
はい 怒り消せましたと
怒ってないんだと 次の瞬間で言えるんですかね
それは言えませんね だからもう怒りの生まれる法則やら
怒りが生まれたらどのようになるかとかね
そういう勉強はもう後からついてくるもんなんですね
だからこの講演会なんかではね
このすごい  得意な顔をして質問する人々っていうのは
そこら辺さっぱりわからない
ただそれだけ見て ああ簡単単純だ
お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
あんた言うことは違いますよと
公の場だからね 私にも何も言えないんですよ
もっとまたまたいろいろ経典がありますよと言ってはありますけどね
いや 私はこの経典で意味を捨ててないんだと
だから言いたいことはいっぱい出てくるんです
それだけで知ったかぶりをする必要ないんですから
これ大変な世界なんです
だから怒りにしたっても
嫉妬も怒りし 悩みも怒りし
ストレス溜まることもね
現代風な言葉ですから
ストレスというのは ストレス溜まることも怒りであるし
それ一切まとめて寸時に消すということ
そこでこちらで次に言ってるのは
それ上手な人 だからもう修行完成者なんです
だからその人には怒りの毒が回らないんです
蛇が来て刺すとしても回らないんだと
そこは他の経典でお釈迦様はもし手に傷跡がないならば
手で毒を捕まっても取っても何のことないんだと
毒蛇 蛇の毒であろうか
もう人間今使ってるあのいろいろな普通な毒ありますね
やっぱり皮膚からも入る毒
今最近使ってますけどね
そこは当時に知らなかったんだからね
皮膚に触れただけで死んでしまっちゃう毒もね
化学兵器として使ってますけどね
まあそういうものを置いておいて
普通の毒なんかはね 手で触ったということで死ぬということはないんです
皮膚で触ったら まあ危ない時もありますけど
特に手のひらだったらよくできてるんですね
手の皮っていうのは何でも触れるように
それでも穴がいっぱいありますよ
汗も出ますから 穴があるんだけど
よくできてる 来たもんで
毒触っても何のこともない
ですから この他のところで心がそのように育てているならば
それも悟りの境地ですよと
そのようにまあたくさん経典の引用はこちらもあるだろうと思いますけど
探すのは難しい そういうことで
この偈を読んだだけで我々はもう完全になるということもありません
これは怒りは蛇の毒のごとく
いわゆる怒りは猛毒ですよと
じゃあ覚えていたんだからといって怒らないわけでもないんですね
もうそれ急用から それだったら水分も軽々とね
人間にとっては問題なく悟れますからね
こちらで言っているのは悟られるんだということ
これ上手になったらそれ自体は悟りなんです
だからこの悟りなんですか
解脱なんですかと 涅槃ってなんですかと
いつでもみんなこのあの世のことを理解したがるでしょう
悟りの境地ってどんな境地ですかと
あれ腹が立つ質問なんです
何ももう頭の思考の働きも分かってない
言語の制限も分かってない
言葉の使い方すら理解していない
言葉はどれぐらい働き持っているかと
そういう何一つもわからない人々が
自分知ってる単語を全て自分の五根の経験でしょうに
綺麗だとか赤いだ青いだとかいうのは全て見たものでしょうに
一度も見たことがない色に言葉がありますかね
一度も食べたことがない味に言葉がありますかね
ないんですね それでまた残念なことに
人間に見れる色っていうのも決まってるんでしょ
だから言葉決まってるんです
人間に味わえる味っていうのは何種類かということ
もの単純明快で決まってるんだから
塩味やら酸味やら甘味やら苦味やらとかね
七つぐらいしかないんですね
まあ色だったらまあほとんど三つで
もう科学者が計算していて
その三つの色でも一万なんとか色とかコンピューターで印着やってますからね
これもう  一万じゃ二万かどっちかのような
もうたくさん色が出てくるんだとかね
あんな色が出てくるわけじゃないんだよ
ただの算術でやってますけどね
で ですからそれしか見えてないはずなんですね
ですから 人間の経験の世界というのはそんなもので
聞こえる音にしたっても
どれぐらいの周波数聞こえるかともう全部もう決まってるんだから
体で感じるもの いろいろ言葉使いますけど
仏教から言うのは体で感じるのはただ二つだけですよと
硬さと温度だけですよ
で 我々の知識の世界というのは
そのようにすっごい単純なものなんです
で そこ言葉全てその中にあるんですよ
言葉はもう四十万個ありますよというふうな言うんですが
結局全てその本当にほんのわずかな経験に基づいで出来立っているもの
で それでもって涅槃ってどんな境地ですかと
説明しなさいと あんた勉強してるんだったら何をと
という態度で質問するんですね
分かってやるぞと で 分かってやるぞと向こう思ってちゃっても
こちらは相手にもしたくないんだと
というぐらいなんで 仏教の立場から見れば
ですから この そういう説明しようとする努力さえも間違っているんです
だから仏教では形而学的な設問
説明入れちゃうと もう仏教が先制てるんです
で なんでそこまで行ったかというと
この涅槃ってなんですかと
説明するとするへりごとなんです
人間単語を持ってないんです
超能力のこととかという言うんだけど
ああいうのは嘘なんです
なぜ嘘かというと そういう経験になってないんです
ああ 分かった分かったって
五根から入った情報しか分かってないでしょうに
ですから この論理成り立たないところで科学では説明できませんと
そんな理屈では説明できませんと
まあそれで処理するんですね
だったら人間らしく 人間にも理解できないんだったら
じゃあもういりませんと言っても構いませんし
だけどわかりやすく言えば
人間に問題あるならば
これは五感から生まれた情報から問題が作られているし
まあ五根でもいいし 六根でもいいし
六根から生まれてくる情報によって
この識り過程によって問題が起きてくるんだから
ですから そこら辺は形而上学なしに具体的に説明できるはずなんです
そういうわけで この偈の中で涅槃の定義もあるんです
見えませんだけど どういうことかというと
この生まれた瞬間に怒りを消す方法を身につけている
それを人間に体験できますからね
それを解脱っていうことなんです
その人は比丘ですよと
だから 人間知ってる世界から説明するんですね
だからまだまだ得て体験してないんだけど
今の体験というの 経験というのは
もう怒りは良くないとはわかってはいるんだけど
もうやめられないと もうすぐ怒ってしまっちゃうということですね
我々経験しているのは
つい怒ってしまう 怒ってもすぐすぐなくならない
延々とこの連鎖反応で
次から次へと怒りがもう続けていっちゃう
怒りとこの放射能ってほとんど同じ働きなんですよ
もう似てるんです ちょっと怒ったら次から次へとそれ広げていっちゃうんですね
例えばAさんと怒ったところで
自分がすごく可愛いと思ってるBさんがそこらへんに入ってきたと
何のことなくその人にも怒ってしまっちゃうんです
その人に対して怒っちゃうと
その人を怒るんです そうすると
それは本物になっちゃうでしょうに
そうすると こちらにいる私がAさんと怒った
そこでは本物の怒りがありますね
実体としての怒りがあります B
さんが来たってBさんに対しては別に怒る必要ないんです
でも自分が怒りを持ってると
すぐそこにそちらにぶつかっちゃう
ぶつかったら その人はわけもなく怒りを投げ捨てられたんだから
その人はわけがあって怒るんです
そうすると 私とBさんの関係でも
また実体として怒りが
あれは成立しちゃうんですね
そこでその人 また怒りというものを持って
それを誰にその毒を回すかと
またわからないんですね
次から次へと回すこともできます
どこまででも で それで怒り自体が毒でしょうし
毒だとわかってもどうしようもないし
一旦入ったら自分を破壊していっちゃうんです
大変苦しみの方に持っていっちゃう
毒入ったら同じことだから
と同じく 自分を破壊の方に
苦しみの方に もう もう導いてしまっちゃうんですね
だからそこを何とかできるかないかと
そこはポイントなんですね
それは自分の心の使い方次第
心の能力次第 その能力を身につけているんだったら
まあ毒がぶつかってきてももう当たらない
全部反射して出て行っちゃう
やる 怒れる条件は変えたわけじゃないんです
我々 普通にみんなと一緒に生きてるんだから
みんなもう九十パーセント怒りで生きてるでしょう
だからいつでもいろんな条件の中で
まあこれも嫌だ あれも嫌だ
この人も嫌だという感じで
なんでうまくいかないんだとか
なんで希望通りにいかないんです
なんで計画通りにいかないんですかとかね
そういう気持ちで生きてるんだから
もう怒りだけなんですね
だからみんな希望しているのは条件変えてほしいと
あれはまるっきり屁理屈なんです
私が怒らないために世界を変えてくれとということを言ってるんですね
平気で言ってるんです
あんたさえそんなことをしなかったら
私は怒りませんと 平気で賢そうに顔して言うんです
だって怒るのは当たり前ではないか
そういうことをするんだからと
ただ それを その屁理屈はあまりにも面白くて
私もよく使うんです 使う
お馴染みに使ってるわけじゃないんです
人はいかにそれを屁理屈だと理解していないかと
私も平気で時々言うんです
あんたそういうことをするんだから怒ってるんだと
ただ 向こう側がもしちょっとでも頭があるんだったらね
あなたの怒りを管理してるのは私ですか？心管理しているのは
怒ったのはあなたの勝手でしょうと
私は何しようか 怒ったことはあなたの責任ではないかとぐらいは言えないんですね
だから私たちは希望しているのは世界変えて
変わってくださいと 子供に対して怒る母親が言うのは
あなたがしっかりしなさいと
おとなしくなりなさい
そうするとお母さんは怒りません
子供のせいなんです お母さん鬼にしないように
立派な人間として育てるために子供が頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
すごい論理なんです だから子供はおとなしくなって
よく勉強して 言うことよく聞いて
真面目に生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
母のために そうでないと母が怒るんだと
だから あまりにも無知な話でしょうに
例えば商売の関係で なんで商人が怒っているのか
あんまり商売がうまくいかないんだから
だから彼が喜んで楽しく生活するために
お客さんがいっぱい来て
わがままを言わないで
こちらの商人が売ってる品物は全部もう買いまくるならば
まあ自分が立派な人間でいるんじゃないかと
ストレスもたまらないで
心配もしないで 悩まないで
悩むこともなく だから人間でよくそこまで言うんですよ
世の中では 世界に平気で言うんですね
世界は変えなさいと 世界はですか
どちらですかね 世界 世界に言うんですね
君は自分を変えなさいと
そうでなきゃ私が怒るんだと
神様気分なんですね 雨に降るなという
雷の落ちるなという 夏に暑くするなという
だって私は怒るんだからと
夏はあまりにも暑くて
湿気がもう九十パーセントぐらいあると
ものすごい地獄みたいに苦しいんですけど
嫌ですね この天気 天気はどうか
向こうに当たるんですね
あれほど愚かなことはないんです
そうやって怒ること自体完全たる無知なんです
そこを理解して智慧が生まれたら
もう怒ること自体馬鹿馬鹿しい
これ私の問題だと だから悟ったんだから
夏も春のごとく涼しくなったとか
そんなことじゃないんです
[背景音楽]そのまんまで
だから怒る条件は今までずっと怒りっぱなしで生きてきた条件
条件はそのまんまで でも自分は怒らないと
心を変えちゃったんだと
今までも完全たるバカな考え方で生きてきたんだけど
これをグッと変えてしまって
もう智慧の人間になりましたと
屁理屈は言わないと 希望しないということになるだけのことなんです
そのことっていうのはいくらか理解できるでしょ
まあなんかありえない話ではないんだと
あの世の話じゃないでしょ
極楽道の話じゃないでしょ
極楽道に行ったら怒りがないんだという話じゃないんだから
人間の娑婆世界にいる限りは怒りがあるんだと
そういうのは屁理屈であって
娑婆世界で怒る人は極楽道に行ったっても怒って阿弥陀様をぶん殴ったりするでしょうと思いますけどね
そこから追い出されて地獄に落ちると
ということにはなりかねませんだからね
ですから そういう話ではなくて
やっぱり怒り 怒る場合は
我々はこの他を害をしているんです
自分には希望があって
ただこうならなくてはならないという基準があって
他は自分が作った基準に合わないと怒るんですね
この問題は自分作った基準が正しいか正しくないかではないんです
例えば子供はよく勉強するべきですよと
それはもう正しい考え方だと思っちゃうでしょ
それで怒るんです あれも屁理屈なんです
だから自分が基準を作ったと
その基準が正しいんだからどうしようもないでしょうと思うところ間違いなんです
だからこちらで基準を作る
基準を作って 他にそれ希望する
他にその希望した基準に合わせてくれないと
こちらで怒りが生まれる
システムをちゃんと理解しなくちゃいけない
だからみんな作る基準も正しい基準
間違ってる基準が当然ありますけど
これ間違ってる基準で怒るのは全くめちゃくちゃですけど
じゃあ正しい基準に怒る
怒ったらどうしますか？それもおかしいんです
基準作った自分が勝手に基準を作ったんだから
私がこう決めたんだから
皆様やってくださいという権利どこに成り立ってるんですかね
私はって何様ですかね
他人に対して だからこの人類というのは
宇宙いうか 生命がそうやってみんな自分が神様気分で生きているんです
だから幸せかというと逆で
最低に不幸なんです 論理的に考えると
生命は平等なんです 私はゴキブリで基準を作ったって
ゴキブリはなんでそれを守らなくちゃいけないんですかね
ゴキブリは家に入ってはいけませんとこちらで勝手に基準を作る
それでそうでしょ？だってそうでしょ
人間に聞いたじゃん それはその通りですよと
正しい みんな決めるんだけど
ゴキブリはなんでその基準に束縛される必要がありますかね
神様の気分なんで それでゴキブリ部屋に入っちゃったらキャーキャーと言って怒って潰したりするんです
だからそこら辺は理屈成り立ってないんだと
子供は勉強するべきですよということは
一般的な正しい基準かもしれませんだけど
だからといって子供は約束に縛られてないんです
徹底的に真面目に勉強しなくちゃあかんという
子供は知らないんだから
そんなことは 大人がそんな基準作ってるんだっていうことは
何も知りませんだから
何も知らない人に勝手に基準をつけてしまって
そこで親が子供に対して怒るでしょうに
だからそうやって正しい基準にしたってもね
あんた万引きしたんだからお母さん怒ってるんだよと
と思ったっても その怒ってるんだよっていうところはおかしいんです
なぜ万引きしたんですか？と聞くのは別におったことないんだけど
あんたそれで楽しいんですか？と
あるいは それで母親を困らせたと思ってるのは全然困ってないんですよ
言っちゃえば別に それっきり万引きしないと思いますけど
勝手にしててくださいと
なんで万引きぐらいいっぺん行って包丁持ってこのコンビニエンスストアでもね
やつけろと やるんだったらしっかりやれと
大きな声で そこ言ってみれば
いっぺんに子供は治るんですよ
だから私言うこと屁理屈と思うでしょ
いえ 私はちゃんと理屈言ってるんです
そういう風に言ってみてください
でも理解して 理解してないんだから
屁理屈の塊の人が理屈使ったっても
もうそれは上手に運転できません
ですから あの 私はこう
もういろいろトラブル起こす子っていうのは一発で直せちゃうんだと
長い間カウンセリングとかそんなことはない
相手が可愛いんだったら
まあ付き合いますけどね
一緒に遊んだりとかね
あまりにも悪いことをしないで
いたずらしないんだったら
まあ一応遊び相手にはしてあげますけど
でも問題があったらもう一回で
ですから この屁理屈のあんたはこういうことをするんだから
お母さん怒ってるんだよと言っていちいち言ったっても
その時でも 子供にとっては別にそれ認める
受け入れる 何て言いますか
もう権利というかね まあそういうふうに束縛されてない
契約はないんです だから我々は誰もお互いに契約を立ててないんです
みんな一個一個生命はそれぞれもう平等で独立なんですけど
なのにこちら勝手に契約作る
だったら やるんだったら契約は大げさにやった方がいいんです
私は全地球支配している大帝王やと
あなた方は私にちゃんと尊敬しなさいと
礼をしなさいと言ってみてください
一人で自分にはいろんな基準作る権利があるならば
どんな基準でもいいでしょうに
子供はよく勉強するべきですよと
あの人はこうやるべきですよとかいう風な基準作るならば
なんでちっぽけな基準作るんですかね
ものすごいでっかい基準作ればいいでしょうし
せっかく作るんだから
そうするとわかるでしょ？その基準作ること自体があまりもバカバカらしいんだと
それはお釈迦様の例えがあります
例えはね 現代我々にちょっと違うところで違うものを説明するために
でも同じ理屈なんですけど
このバラモン人に怒ってお釈迦様おっしゃった言葉なんですけど
ある人は豚を取ってきて
そこを殺して 肉を肉にして
それから肉も魚も大嫌いな人がいるんだと
その人に私は豚を殺して肉にちゃんとカットして作ったんだから
あんた買いなさいよと
別に私食べたくない でも私がこれ作ったんだから
どうするんですか それは
あんた買わなかったら全部捨てなくちゃいけないんだよと言って脅して
その肉も食べたくもない肉嫌い人に肉を売ってお金をもらうんだと
じゃあちゃんとお金払えと
現金で そうだったら それあまりにも不公平でしょ
相手はもともと肉は食べない人で
こちらは勝手に豚を持ってきて殺したんであって
それで一日も冷蔵庫もない時代だから
その日で売らなくちゃいけないんです
あの人に強引に 押し売りする
押し売りしてお金までもらっちゃうんだと
バラモン人に同じこう言ったんです
あなた方はバラモン人が神の口から生まれたんだと
他の連中は足の裏から生まれた
だからあんた方は偉いんだと
あなた方にみんな尊敬しなくちゃいけないということは
こういうことと同じですよと
だから理屈は同じでしょ
この例えから見ても お釈迦様の論理は
だからこちら勝手に基準を作ったっても
他人がそれに契約に結ばれてないんです
でないのにも関わらず
我々は自分の主観でいっぱい基準を作る
これ ずっと人間の心の働きなんですね
こうあるべき こうあるべきではないと
その基準の塊で生きていて
であるならば 怒りの塊で生きてるんです
なぜならば 実際の世界では誰一人も契約で結ばれてないんだから
自分を作った基準は守ってくれないんですね
また どんな基準を作ってるか分からないでしょうに
時々人に怒られる場合あるでしょ
我々も別に何の悪いことしたわけじゃないんです
例えば分かりやすい例で言うならば
初めて外国人 日本に来た外国人がいて
もう部屋に呼ばれたんだと
家に来てくださいと 呼ばれた瞬間
その人そのまま部屋に入るとしてたところで怒られる
で 外国人 なんでこんなせっかく私を呼んで
私も日本に初めてだからね
まあこれはいいチャンスだと思って
友達作るために だったのに
この人の態度は何ですか？と
それどういうことかというと
こちらには日本では基準があるんですね
部屋に入る時は靴を脱ぎなさいと
その人はその基準を知らないんですね
だからそれは分かりやすい例でしょうし
ですから そのように私たちがいろいろ基準作るんだけど
相手が知らないんで そんなことは
我々はゴキブリに対して基準作るんだけど
ゴキブリにとって関係ないんですね
だから母親は子供に基準を作ったっても
子供にとっては関係ないんです
そんな話は聞いてないんだと
聞いてないもん ただ生まれたんだだけのことだから
だから 存在の次元で見ると
そういう基準は一つも成り立たないということは
ものすごいわかりやすい論理なんですね
それ理解すれば怒りが消えていっちゃうんです
いわゆる主観が消えるという状況なんです
主観が消えたら もうあるのは客観だけであって
客観的な理解だけであって
そうすると心には何も怒りということは生まれてこないんですね
そこのシステムができた人はここで比丘と言うんですね
だから涅槃解脱というのはそれなんです
だから人間の言葉で理解しようとするならば
形而上学的な話ではなくて
この我々の現在の心の働きの中から解脱と涅槃と
定義できるんです それで納得いかないで
涅槃をしてからどうなるんですかとまた質問するんですね
そこは説明できません
なぜならば単語ないんだから
持っている単語それしかないんだから
1万円札を持って 40カラットのダイヤ買おうと
買いませんよ そういうことだといったっても
やっぱり人間は物事は論理的に理解しておかないと
論理的に理解してなくてもいい
いいんであるならば 何を信じてもいいでしょうね
それだったら 論理的でないものは世の中にあるんだと
科学的に説明できないものは世の中にあるんだと
それを信じるんだと言ったら
何を信じてもいいでしょうに
それだったら 論理的でないものは何でも
ですから そんな話はね
あまり認めるわけにはいきません
例えば ハンドパワーで癌が治りましたと
本当かと 嘘やと あなた方にはね
論理的に説明できませんだけど
科学的に説明できませんだけど
癌が治りましたと それを信じるんだったら
やっぱりあなたは 2週間経ったところで犬になるんだと
嘘より確実に犬になるんだと言ってもいいんです
なぜかというとですね
では説明して 科学的に説明できませんと
これ論理的に説明できませんと
でも  2週間経ったらあんた確実に犬になるんだ
それで 2週間経ってからその人が来て
ほら見てください 犬になってないで
あなた犬ですよ もうとっくに犬ですよ
言っちゃえばいいでしょうに
だから論理的でないもの
非科学的でない 科学で説明できないものもあるんだ
信じるべきだというならば
そういうことになるんです
ですから この偈の ちょっと 1偈の中で
私はこの 1偈だけ説明していて
いかにこの複雑で難しいかっていうことね
その 1偈の中で解脱のところまでちゃんと言葉でもって定義しているんです
怒りをちゃんとなくすことができるかと
できたならば その人は比丘であって
その人はこの世もあの世も捨てるんだと
蛇が皮を捨てるようにと
古い皮を捨てるように捨てるんだと
それでなんでこの世 あの世を捨てるというんですか？そこにもポイントがあるんです
世の中で一切の宗教はあの世のためなんです
成仏のため 極楽道のため
天界に生まれ変わるため
この世を捨ててあの世をつかまえるためなんです
お釈迦様はこの世もあの世も捨てるんだと
そこで仏教と他の宗教のそこら辺違うかと
ただそれだけでわかるはずなんです
このあの世と言えばものすごい大きな言葉でしょ
その各宗教によってあの世の定義は違う
仏教においても あの世の定義はもうそれぞれ違う
ヒンドゥー教のあの世の定義はそれぞれ違う
どんな定義であろうが
全て二言葉にすれば この世
あの世ですからね で 彼岸に行くんじゃなくて
彼岸と何岸？え？此岸
だから此岸も捨てて彼岸も捨てる
だからこのお釈迦様の教えの場合ははっきりとこの世も捨てる
あの世も捨てるという
この二言葉で仏教はどこまで違うかと
で それくらいでわかると思います
一応その偈の意味はまあそれぐらい
ぐらいで理解しておけばいいんじゃないかなと思います
この一つの偈で悟りと解脱の定義と
そちらの解脱の心の転換度のようなものかとっていうことも入っていて
それから人類にとっては大変な問題として見ると
この怒りということなんです
それは猛毒と見てみるべきですよ
ということで この詩記で書いているんです
詩記だけ そうやってこの
この蛇の経典は全てこの解脱を涅槃という仏教の究極的な境地を書いているんです
一つ一つ全てこれどれぐらいあります？ 十七まであります
十七まで ですから この日本語訳で軽々く読むんだけど
これ全て仏教の究極的な境地のことを説明してるんです
それから 一つ一つ この十七の一個一個インディペンデント
独立しているんです だから一個の式だけで十分です
だから 一番目から二番目に行きますとか
二番目から次の目に行きますということじゃなくて
全部ソートラなんですね
フォーミュラなんですね
涅槃の解脱という究極的な境地を説明する式
式たくさん使っているんです
まあこれ言葉たくさん使ってるけど
式だから同じ 同じですけどね
でもまあ一偈で終わっちゃいますから
まあ一応早くもう一つ読んでみましょう
ヨー
ラーガンウダチッダーアセサン・ビスプッパンワ・サロールハン・ヴィガイハ・ソービクク・ジャハティ・ヨーラ・パーラン・ウラ・ゴーチンナ・ニワタ・チャン・プラーナン
ヨ
ーラーガンウダチッダーアセサン・ビスプッパンワ・サロールハン・ヴィガイハ・ソービクク・ジャハティ・ヨーラ・パーラン・ウラ・ゴーチンナ・ニワタ・チャン・プラーナン
ということで これまた簡単で
次にこのラーガン まあ欲のこと
だから人間の悩み苦しみはほとんど怒りと前説明したんだけど
また逆に人間のトラブルは全部欲から生まれるっていうことは簡単に言うんですよ
結局もう欲だからでしょうし
やっぱりね まあ欲っていうのはまあ良くなりたいということだからね
成長したいとか美しくなりたいと楽になりたいと
みんなと仲良くしたいと
有名になりたい 大物になりたい
ひと財産作りたいとかね
外車に乗りたいと 世界旅行したいとか
いろいろ気持ち 希望 まあそれぞれもう望みあるでしょうね
世の中には 全て世界規模でまとめてみればね
すっごい大変でしょう
そんななりたいって思っただけでなれるわけじゃないし
それのみなら 損害 いじめ
いっぱいしなくちゃいけないんですよ
その中でいろんなバカなことをしたり
事実を曲がったりとかね
例えば政治家の世界でね
世界ではね 大物になりたい国は自分の敵に
ある国を敵に回す わざと敵に回すんです
敵に回して潰すんですね
潰したところで自分が力持ちになるんです
別にどうったことないかもしれませんだけどね
それはわざとなんでそんなことをするんですか？絶対許せません
わざと相手を敵に回して
自分が大なる国になる
インチキなんです ソ連がアフガニスタンに入ったでしょ
昔は あれは強引に戦略したわけじゃないんです
その政府も もう来てくださいと
助けてくださいと 大変やと
ということで協力あって入ったもんなんですね
だから入ったことは正しいか
これは関係ない話で 我々にとってはある人々が
政権転覆とか 人々が自分の政治論としてはソ連を認めていることだから
私は誰の政治論も正しいと思ってないし
ですから まあそこはその人は正しい
だから来てくださいと言ったところで
ソ連軍隊がアフガニスタンに入りましたと
そこは世界的にとんでもない戦略だと
だからオリンピックなんかに参加するなと
日本も参加しなかったでしょう
あの馬鹿げた話に引きずられて
ソ連潰すってことになっちゃう
じゃあそれぐらい人間の味方になったこの国がどれぐらい国を攻めたんですかね
その後でも だから他人に破壊した量を見ると
誰の方が大げさかね やっぱりそうやって人間っていうのは
ただ単に我々は偉大になると
世界で最もパワフルだと
一番力持ちやと ということで
まあそうするためにいろんなからくりをして
からくりをして からくりをしてと
だからもう結局一番力持ちという幻覚に陥るだけで
別に力持ちでもなんでもないし
心理的に 漆なものもないし
絵画と音楽ぐらい もうインチキなね
加工したものしか漆なものを持ってないし
やっぱりそうやって まあなんとなくこのインチキ的に
もうからくりで もう力持ちという錯覚に陥るし
そのためにいろんな人々が大変損害を
ダメージを受けなくちゃいけない
だからそのシステムっていうのはいつでも世の中で欲なんですね
あるんですね だから欲だけ見ても
世の中っていうのは まあそうやってお金のため
この経済状態はね それもそういうことでしょう
インチキでしょう ロシアをね
騙して騙して脅して こうしなさい
ああしなさい こうしなさいと
そこで政府もやっぱりヨーロッパを応援してるんだから
ヨーロッパといったってアメリカの方でお金出して出して出して商売やらせて
全部借金だからいきなり全部パーっていうことにしちゃいますから
ローンだけ残って実体はなし
たくさんローンしたっても
買った品物あるんだったら実体はあるんだけどね
実体はないことにする
潰すでしょ それ一方的に儲かるためなんです
だから欲があると いかに苦しみ生まれてくるかと
例えば ほんのわずかでも日本の経済状態がなんとか
なんとかなろうとすると
すぐ円のあれ変わっちゃうでしょ
日本のお金なんですけど
誰かさんが決めるんです
それ決めちゃったら いくら日銀でドルをいっぱい買って買って
もう円売りして自分で損したっても
あれは変わらないんです
そのままです やっともう頭上げるところじゃないんですよ
やっとね まぶた動かそうとしただけのところなんですけど
じゃあ目を覚めて起きようかなというもの
後の話なんです そのところでまた潰しちゃうと
そういう風に考えるとね
まあ我々個人個人で見ても欲で困っているしね
そんなことをしたい あれしたい
これしたいと これしたいのはいいんだけど
そのためにかなり損 かなりダメージ
他人に強いなくちゃいけないんですね
子供は私は外国に行ってもう留学したい
アメリカへ留学したいと言っちゃうと
欲でしょうに 本人がそのために両親にはいくものすごいダメージをしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
行きたいと言ったってお金持ってるわけじゃないし
それ両親がもう全部支えてくれるんだっていうことで
行きたいとわがまま言うだけ行かしてやれば
それから毎日毎日心配して心配して
電話かけて電話かけてちゃんとお金を送って
もう毎月毎月 これ大変なもう苦労でもあって
苦しみであって ダメージでもありますよ
だから本人が海外アメリカへ行って遊んだ
帰ったというだけでね
もう外国旅行して頭がよくなって帰った人はほとんどないんだからね
ただ遊んで帰ったということなんですけど
本人にとってはいいかもしれませんだけどね
どれぐらいダメージになるかと
ですから この欲という働きも怒りという働きとも同じことで
大変な問題なんです こちらの例えはウダチッダ
ウダチッダっていうのは
この根元から取るという
根元からいわゆる まあいわゆる日本訳では追って取る取るという意味で
まあその意味でもいいんですけどね
そうそうそう アセーサンっていうのは残りなく
何か残ったっていうことじゃないんですね
余ることなく で あの単語を日本語で言えばバラバラですけどね
単語の並び替えは これはパーリ語の並び替えで
パーリ語ではすごい美しい
ものすごい美しい並び替えなんです
日本語になるともうすごいバラバラなんですけど
ビサプッパン ビサプッパンっていうのはこの蓮華の花ですね
初の花 サロールハンっていうのはこの池のこと
湖 池 イガイハという言葉の意味っていうのは捕まってとって
捕まる グラスという 捕まる
それだけで文章にならないでしょ
結局は ラーガン怒り ウダチッダ
まあね 孤独にありはもう全く取るとという
アセーサン残りなく それから初の花
サロールハン 初の花のようにと
サロールハンというのは池
イガイハっていうのは捕まって
だからこれ文章にするともうかなり苦労しなくちゃいけない
だからこれ詩記だから余計なものは全部もう取ってるんです
言葉として意味取れるギリギリのところまで言葉短くして作るんです
ですから これを翻訳できないんですよ
翻訳するといっぱいもう補うんです
だから翻訳したっていうのは
この元の下にある美しさと
このギュウギュウ 意味がね
ものすごいギュウギュウ詰めにあること
これは感じられないんです
だから意味はね 日本訳を読めばわかるでしょうと思います
この欲があったら欲あったら
それはこの ハスの蓮華の花っていうのは
やっぱりまた生まれないように取りたければ
花だけ折ってもダメなんです
花取ったんだからもう終わりだということじゃないんです
中根っこがあるんだからね
それだったらさら池の中に入って
根元からつかまって全部取り出さないと
また出てくる可能性あります
ハスの花よりは何かもっと余計な役に立たない他の雑草のこと使っても良かったかもしれません
だけど やっぱりお釈迦様はハスの花使った
例としてね また他の水の中にきて
本当に邪魔な植物 邪魔って人間の立場から邪魔なんですけどね
で あるんですけどね やっぱりよく考えるとハスの花の例えは合うんです
なぜならば これ欲のことでしょ
だからハスの花自体が見て悪いと気持ち悪いと思うこともないんですね
ああ綺麗と という だから欲ってのはそんな感情でしょ
欲は悪いと人間思わないんです
欲が悪いと思う人間がいません
例えば勉強したいなと
これ欲ですよと だから何が悪いんですかということでしょうね
やっぱり死ぬまで安定して生活生きているために
きっと財産作りたいなと
あんた欲張りですね これは言ったら言われた側が馬鹿にされるだけで
そういうのは世の中に普通に悪いとは思わないんです
だから欲っていうのは普通の世界では美徳なんです
でも怒りは美徳じゃないんですね
怒りの場合はみんなカウンセリング受けちゃうんです
ですから 怒りは毒 毒の
蛇の毒に例えて 欲はハスの花に例えて
よくできてるでしょ でも
あの 死ぬ場所 池 こうありますね
だからハスの花は咲いて綺麗なんですけど
池は真逆で残酷なんですね
池はないんです 結局は
全部もうやられちゃって
もし放っておけば もう水がなくなっちゃって
もうハスの葉っぱが出て出て
あっちこっちからいっぱい栄養あるでしょ
水の中に だから結局この雑草みたいな感じで
もう邪魔になっても池もなくして自分を自滅するんです
だから我々は一つ二つだけ見て
ああ ハスの花は綺麗だ
この池はね ほんのちょっと花が一つだけ咲いて綺麗やと思うんだけど
放っておいてみてくださ
い だから普通の我々作る花だったら毎日面倒見なきゃ機嫌だから
そうですね 言ってしまってはハスの花は違うんです
放っておけば置けば どんどんどんどん出てくるんです
だから 一本のほんのちょっとの根なんですけど
細くて それがどんどん太くなって
そこからこちらからあっちからで
こうまた枝が出ていって
あれ網の如く根がいくんです
言って こっちからこっちから出てきて
もうすごい状態になっちゃうんですね
だから欲もそういうことで
網の如く増えちゃうんです
例えば一戸建てを作りたいなと思っちゃう
それ欲なんですけどね
それだったらかなり苦労しなくちゃいけない
かなり家族にダメージをしなくちゃいけない
会社のお金も横領しなくちゃいけないとか
いろいろ出ちゃうんですね
上司をごまかさなくちゃいけない
そういうことをやって
まあ一戸建てを作ったとする
そうすると まあせっかくだから車も買おうと
なっちゃうでしょ 犬を飼おうと
もうもう飼えるんだから
今までマンションでしたから
アパートでしたから 犬を飼えなかった
やっぱり網のように欲っていうのは増えて増えて結果としては本人が欲で喜んだことはないんです
わかってないだけで さんざんやられただけなんです
欲に操られたんです もう散々苦労しただけなんです
時々高いお金で立派な家なんかね
買ったりするでしょ それから奴隷みたいに
まあ家の掃除ってのは大変なんです
高い絨毯なんか敷けてみたら
もう毎日丁寧に掃除しないと
あれふわふわの中にね
いっぱいダニとかね 成長しちゃうし
そこで最新型の風呂とかなんかあったら気をつけないと
ちょっとでも故障したら全部パーいかれちゃうんです
大変 だから結局かっこいいと
楽だと やってはいるんだけど
もう大変なんです だからどこら辺楽でどこら辺苦しいかともう見当もしないんです
時々このあれ 東京のあのあそこ
田園調布ですか で 昔はもうすごいね
金持ちでもう財産 大きな家なんか造ったって
このテレビでもちょっと随分前なんですけど
あの どんどん見せる 前は家の土地が大きくあって
その人死んだところで
この何とか税金ですか
あれは あの相続税払うためにこれぐらいのものは売ってしまって
そこの人を死んじゃったらこれぐらい売ってしまって
そこで一向の一つの意識今残ってないんです
そこで その人がの息子はもう大人で普通の社会人ですけど
今困ってるんですね 父親が死んじゃったら
この全部これも売って
もう田園調布にさよならと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
そこまではいいかも 楽かもしれませんだけど
どこかであの 生活するのは
やっぱりああいうでっかい建物にいた時もね
それは維持すること 管理することをね
またお手伝いにも人を雇わなくちゃいけないこととかね
そういうことを考えると
まあもしベッドルーム3つがあったらね
もう まあ日本であまりないんだけどね
まあ外国だったらね まあもう全部トイレット付きでベッドルーム二つ
三つっていうのは一般的にあること
タオルのを洗うタオルとベッドシート
それぐらい考えて どれぐらい洗濯しなくちゃいけないかと
大変です 重労働なんです
たとえ機械でやったっていうのも
アイロンかけなくちゃいけない
それに時間ないと誰かを雇わなくちゃいけない
そういうことで この まあ欲は悪いと誰も思わない
誰も思わないんだからといって
だからということじゃないんで
仏教はそんなこと言ってるわけじゃないんです
誰も思わないんだからって
正しいわけじゃないんだけど
だから欲は美しい蓮の花にはもう花には例えてます
でも 蓮の花の状況っていうのは
いつでも網のように水の中で広げて広げていって
いろんなところで咲いてしまう
だから花がたくさん咲くような感じで
欲もたくさん咲くんです
一つで終わることはないんです
いっぱい増えていっちゃいますね
それでどこら辺楽しみかと
[背景の音楽]例えば若い二人が結婚したりする
この人はかっこいいんだとかわいいんだと思って結婚したりする
それ一つの花が咲いたような感じなんです
それから住むところ探したり
家を守ったり 料理したり
それからどこまで楽しくてどこまで大変かと計算してみちゃうと
誰も計算しないんだからいいんですけどね
で やっぱり子どもいた方がいいかと
また新しい花が欲しくなっちゃうんですね
その前に何かこれも買った方がいい
これも買った方がいいとかね
いろんな花が咲いてきて
それでじゃあ子供作らなくちゃいけない
それまた新しい花が 子供出てきたらそれでおもちゃ買わなくちゃいけないし
それで 1ヶ月とかの間に子供が大きくなっちゃいますと
おもちゃも買い替えなくちゃいけないし
大量にガラクタ溜まっちゃうし
それでやっと歩けるところ
小さな三輪車買ってあげなくちゃいけないし
それも 1ヶ月と2ヶ月間でもう終わっちゃう
もう次のものを買ってあげなきゃ
こうやっていろいろ それからそれだけ楽しいんだけど
育てる過程の苦しさっていうのは
それ大変ですからね でもどんな新しい花が咲くでしょうね
じゃあ小学校に行くって連れて行くわとかね
まあいろいろいろいろ七五三とか次から次へと
七五三自体は楽しいんだけど
そこまでの準備とお金とか考えちゃうと
女の子の七五三見たことは参加したことあるんだけど
結局女の子泣いてるんですよ
朝起きると次の日はもうワクワクしてね
明日もう七五三だとかね
遊んだりはするんだけど
本当になってくると もうどんどんどんどんいろいろ衣装を変えたり
もう神社に行く前にもう飽きてるんです
子供は疲れて だからなんとかお菓子を持って写真撮る
これ強引にもう頼んでお願いしますから
もう泣かないでちゃんとニコッと笑ってよとか言って
もうやっともう写真撮る
それまた綺麗に載って
いやー可愛かったとかね
本人はすぐ忘れるんだから
子供はね いいんだけど
可愛かったんじゃなくて地獄でしたよと子供は言うでしょう
おそらく だからそうやって
このちょっと客観的に見ると
このもう花だけではなくて
やっぱり花の後ろに泥があって
ハツの花でもあるいは芯にはトゲがあるんです
だからトゲまであるんです
それで怒りは基準から生まれる説明しましたね
欲はどこから生まれるんですかね
だから欲は逆の働きなんですね
あれは自分にとっては一応基準がないんです
原理主義的なことなんですけど
基準がないんです あれ面白い
買ってやろう 買おうと
あ これ面白い だからこれも買おうと思うことなんです
自分に基準があったら
私にとっては人の人間だから
これぐらいで十分だよという基準がないんです
基準がないことで欲が生まれてくるんです
その基準と怒りの基準はそういうものが質が違います
それで樽をひっくり返すんです
だからもう結構ということが生まれてこないんですね
心の中に まあこれで十分やと
基準がないと増えて増えて増えていくものなんですね
欲っていうのは だから欲っていうのは体のことなんですよ
見るもの聞くもののことなんです
そちらには基準あるんです
もともと 人と違って 一人の人間に見られるものはもう決まってて
聞こえるもの決まってあって
量も決まってるんで 残念ですけど
耳に聞こえる 聞く量も
それ早く聞いてしまっちゃったら耳が聞こえなくなっちゃう
見える量もこの肉体の構成だから
これぐらいしか見えませんとエネルギーが決まってるんです
見るたびに白球っていうものは使って使って使ってもう終わりましたと
だから 原理備全身にはもう量が決まってて
一応もともと基準があるので
それ忘れてしまって もっと美味しいものを食べたいと
このもっとというところはおかしいんですね
だから 明日食べたサンドイッチより美味しいものを食べたいというならばね
まあわかる でもそれもまあ危ないんだけど
いくらかもっと美味しいものを食べたいという基準で一生生きていますからね
で そういうことで もっと楽をしたいとかね
もっと体を楽しみたいということが出てきて
家が忙しがってるかってことを忘れちゃうんですね
家に行ってしまっちゃう
だから基準がないんだから飛んじゃうんですね
で もともと欲に赴く場合は基準があるんです
人が一生食べられる量と
聞こえる音の量と 見るものの量っていうのも決まってあって
それはどんどん減っていくんだから
我々の老いるってそういうことなんですね
目がもうどんどん弱くなったんだっていうことは
もういっぱい見たんだっていう
もう採算は消えていた
心臓が弱くなった 腎臓がもう
まあ肝臓でしたっけ？liverとかね
まあ一応もう働かなくなったっていうと
あんたはもう全部使ったんだと
だから寿命はまだ先にあるんだけど
これしょうがないんです
四歳でもう肝臓やられたならば
もう使いすぎ すべて使い
使い なんていますか 尽くしてるんですね
だからそこを先にやられる
それから大変なの 美味しいんだからって言って食べたり飲んだりしてたところでやられちゃうでしょうに
あれ一生適当に分けて食べるべきでしたけどね
誰かでしたっけ？耳が聞こえない音楽家いたんですね
あの  ベートーベン  ベートーベン
だから聞きすぎですね
全部自分にを使って終わりました
それでも聞こえない 今もまあいっぱいいますからね
ずっともうバンバンバン
全部壊れちゃいます だから
これよく耳がいいよりもすごい真剣に聞くんです
真剣に聞くんだから 一曲だけなんで聞くの
それ以上聞こえない 聞こえないというか
ものすごく疲れるんです
重労働みたいで それをやめて
もう静かにそれからっていうことで
だからもうどんどん聞け
どんどん 本当に欲の働きがわかってると
これどんどん聞けではないんです
疲れるんです やっぱりこれやめて一休みしようということになっちゃうんです
だからずっとヘッドフォンしてる
音楽を聞いてる人々は
おそらく聞いてないでしょうね
[音楽]もし真剣に 例えば集中して聞いてみると
すごい疲れるっていうことがわかるでしょうと思います
あれはもう3分流れる音楽ったって
ほんのちょっと聞いて
ほんのちょっと聞いてだからね
だからもう一日中聞いていられるような錯覚しますけどね
結構疲れます そういうことで
この欲には基準がありますけど
そこを忘れてしまって
もっと欲しいということで
この欲はどんどんどんどん膨張する
それで本人も早く死んじゃう
早く苦しみを受けるし
何ならの損害 苦しみ 他人にも与えて
そこでまた不満で死ぬ
だからもう一つ欲が生まれる原因がありますけど
今日は時間もないし 一応もう一つは
この一般的に渇愛という足らないという感覚なんですね
足らない なんでもっと美味しいものを食べたいと思いますか？足らないっていう感じなんですね
この味は なんでこの味足らないと思いますかね
食べてない 集中して で
飲み込むだけで 大きな高級レストランに行ったところで
豪華に見ても混乱状態で
なんて言いますか 常光状態で心が
ただ格好つけてるだけで
じっとそこを全て味わって
食べ物を味わって 一回食べたらもう一生いいやということになるんです
結構疲れて だからこの即席にいる人々は欲がすきやすきやと言うんだけど
欲の楽しみ方をわかってないんですよ
例えば映画見たってもいいんだけど
厳密に集中して見た方がいいんです
全て 一コマごとに 見るとあれかなり重労働なんです
誰が見たことにもなります
音楽もまあ全部 それで
ああもういいやと もう結構だという気持ちになりますし
疲れます そうじゃなくて
座ってこっち見たり あっち見たり
喋ったり ポップコーン食べたり
ポテトチップス食べたり
トイレに行ったり また入ったり
それでじゃあ来週はあの映画見ようともなっちゃうんですね
無駄ですね あれはお金の無駄遣い
楽しんでないんです そういうことだから
この常光状態で本当は音楽も楽しんでない
食べ物も楽しんでない
香りも楽しんでないんだから足らないと
と気持ちが生まれてくるんです
だから集中力さえあれば
その問題は消えちゃうんです
なんでこのサティを実践すると欲が少なくなるかというと
サティを実践しながらやっちゃうと
厳密にその経験を味わうことができるんですね
食べる時でも スローモーションで実況しながら食べると疲れるんですよ
でも 生まれて初めてその食べ物の味がわかるんです
味も感触もすべてわかるんです
だからすぐ満足感が出てくるんです
あれも食べたい これも食べたいって
こうやって限りなく欲ががんのように広げることはなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この足らないと
満たしてないという この渇愛ということがあって
それも我々は集中していないんだから
集中力ないんだから 出てくる問題で
病気だからね ようなこと
いい加減に そのシステム理解すると
もう心には欲は全くなくなって消えてしまう
だから欲が八つの花にたとえても疲れるんですよ
ものすごく グルメはいいんだけど
もう高血圧やらコレステロールやら糖尿病
ものすごいありったけの病気が出てきて
体が早く壊れて疲れちまうんですね
そういうわけで 欲から脱出した方が一番いいということになるのです
欲は楽しいじゃないと言っているわけでないんです
でも疲れます 人間には欲の楽しみ方は間違っている
みんな無駄遣いしています
映画の例で見ればね もう言って
もう喋っているんだから
いろんなことをやったりしているんだから
だから見てないんですね
ちらちらと見ただけ だから見ましたと
という充実感 満足感は生まれません
もっと面白い映画ないかという気持ちしか生まれてこない
だから どんなつまらないと思う映画でも真剣に見ると
みんな必死になって演じることやら
それで演じることの下手やら上手なことやらね
いろんなカラクリやるの分かってくる
それぐらいでも十分ですよ
今だったらね コンピューター技術とかいろいろ作ってるんだから
これはリアルじゃなくて
これはコンピューターで作ったもので
まあ付いているのは人の体を合体させてるんだとかね
まあそうやってテクニカルの目で見たって
ストーリー自体が面白くなくても
その辺は面白いし だからそうやって本当に集中して見ちゃうと
もう足らないっていう気持ちにはならないんですね
十分という気持ちにはなります
とにかくそれでも疲れる
ですから まあ結局は疲れますから
欲はやめた方がいいということになります
でも簡単にはやめられませんよ
これはすごい心の変化っていうものが起こらないと
怒りとなる 欲は大変だと分かったっても
それはもう無理です 苦しみになりますからね
そのシステム分かった人が
この世の雨もすっ飛ばす蛇が脱皮するようにと
じゃ 以上です  [拍手]